when it comes to selling a screenplay
what are some of the mistakes that you
see a lot of screenwriters make the
mistakes would be desperation insistence
you know where it's you know no you have
to read this minds the only story and
you know the more persistent and
desperate you are the more people back
off I mean think of it if you were
dating you know no you have to go out
with me and this is why you know that's
charming right yeah so it's when I see
people do that immediately you know they
just they just sort of ruined it
the people that let allow the breathing
room in the relationship and let the
words make somebody come to them that's
where you know deals happen sales happen
but again remember this is mainly about
getting your career going this might be
where you're hired
you're not always gonna sell a
screenplay that screenplay is gonna sell
you well it sounds like that's where
charisma it comes back into play so how
does that work and I'm sure in LA it's
slightly different than in other parts
of the country but how do people develop
that charisma where they're not too
pushy but at the same time not too meek
you know I may have expressed or wrong
when talking about charisma I was
talking about with the people who make
it I see like some some writers are very
good about getting their stuff out in
the world that still has to be a good
product that they're getting out and
some people are just very good at the
page but they still have to be decent
enough in a room that they don't scare
people off it really is a mixture of
both those things but the kind of
charisma we're talking about doesn't
have to be like you know big bold shiny
charisma we're just talking about sort
of an authentic connection I know that
entity is used a lot but there's
something to that you know the idea that
you feel like you're talking to a real
person who has a story that they want to
tell who you know it's it's there and
it's the the possibilities of it are
exciting
that the writer has made those
possibilities evident to the listener
like this is what I'm trying to get out
there isn't that interesting oh yeah
that's interesting to me too okay I'll
read it I heard a phrase used the other
day a walking hidden agenda and I think
that sometimes that's when we're trying
to push our stuff out there we can come
across like that we don't mean to it's
just that we're very excited about
something so I think that's a very
negative sort of term but it's actually
very linked a lot of people shy away
from it in LA because everybody does
have something here they're pitching
maybe it's not a hidden agenda but how
can someone sort of like be excited
about it but not be too aggressive and
if they're working a room with some
passion passion okay could think of
instead of like I have a need it's I
have a passion oh you know and I think
that that would that would work
excellent a walking hidden agenda that
sounds like a really good character
description for like like a an
antagonist oh she's just a walking
hidden agenda about that yeah I know
when I heard it I just lit up Wow
you